hi there it's i think day 46 it's my
wife's birthday
we golfed for
two and a half rounds i guess 18 and
about five it
rained off and on
i didn't do much studying of korean
uh i had a bit of a workout but i guess
can't get away from listening to russian
because it's so interesting to follow
all the events that are happening now in
uh
in russia and ukraine and so forth
hopefully that doesn't destabilize the
world too much or lead to any loss of
life
um
what can i say once you've learned a
language like russian
it's just so rewarding to be able to do
things like listen to radio and get a
totally different perspective on events
and so i downloaded uh four or five
interviews and listened to that while
working out and listened to it here
while my wife's watching golf on tv in
our room just before we go to bed and
i'm sitting here listening to russian
while i watch the golf
so i'm enjoying the work that i put into
russian before and that's kind of
delaying my korean
uh
gee i don't know when i get back to
working hard on korean it may not be
until i get back to
vancouver on wednesday and back to my
normal routine but i did do a bit of
korean today just a little bit reading
an article
again uh from chosen elbow so that's it
today that's all you're gonna get bye
for now